سبايدر سبايدر
من الاشخاص التجمع قرب موقع الاعتصام
يمكنكم ان تروا هذا الطريق الذي يبعد نحو
نصف كيلو متر من موقع التظاهر وحول جميعها
هذه التقاطعات تتدفق حشود من الذين
يحاولون الانضمام للاعتصام لكنهم لا
يستطيعون الحكومه عطلت من خلال اضراب غير
رسميا حركه النقل لمنع الناس من الوصول
الى العاصمه منعت الحافلات والشاحنات واي
حركه للنقل اعتقل الاف الاشخاص وهم
يحاولون الوصول الى دكه وقعت حوادث مشابهه
الاربعاء بعد اقتحام قوات الامن مقر حزب
بنغلاديش القوميه المعارض خلال الاحتجاجات
قتل من اعضاء المعارضه شخص واحد على الاقل
برصاص الشرطه وجرح مئات اخرون بينهم بعض
عناصر الشرطه ادانت الامم المتحده
والولايات المتحده وعدده من السفارات
الغربيه العنف
واد اسود
الان اذ ليس من الواضح الى اين تتجه هذه
الاحداث المطلب الرئيسي لاحزاب المعارضه
واستقاله حكومه الشيخ حسينه والتحذير
الانتخابات الجديده تديرها حكومه تصريف
اعمال محايده التظاهرات لا تقتصر على
المعارضه هناك كثير من الناس الذين انضموا
للمتظاهرين بسبب غلاء المعيشه والاوضاع
الاقتصاديه وهناك تحديات كبرى تقع على
عاتق الحكومه حاولت الحكومه ايقاف
المظاهرات لكن المعارضه واصلت التظاهر
بحدود ضخمه في انحاء البلاد على مدار
الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه على الاقل سبعه
اشخاص قتلوا خلال هذه الفتره وجوري حمئات
الاشخاص اعتقل الاف وليس واضحه الى اين
ستتجه الامور في الايام والاشهر المقبله